[Music]
james bond bond
james bond ian fleming's ultimate secret
agent james bond has been featured
consistently in films ever since dr no
debuted in 1962
and many facets of this character have
remained unchanged over the years he's
always been fast with a quip shocking
armed with a gadget collection that
would make sharper image blush and he's
been remarkably consistent with his
cocktail order lorca martini shaken
who's turned vodka martini shaken not
stuff vodka martini shaken not stirred
but as with any film franchise
stretching across multiple decades the
bond films have changed with the times
here's how the james bond franchise has
evolved over the years starting with the
sean connery era and not including
1967's casino royale because it's not
neon production and come on it stinks
[Music]
let's begin at the beginning
sean connery was the first actor to play
james bond on screen and was a relative
unknown in 62 when he made his doctor no
debut except for all you darby o'gill in
the little people stands you're out
there represent are you sure i am as
such connery defined the character as we
know him today his bond is suave sexy
and fearless he's the perfect gentleman
and the masculine ideal and he's
entirely dedicated to queen and country
never doubting the importance of his
mission and his sacred duty to see it
through to the end in some ways the
performance from all future bond actors
act as responses to the connery original
tweaking or even upending some element
of his classic formula to help redefine
the character for a new generation of
fans these early missions and the
villains behind them also helped
fine-tune and hone the formula and
structure that continued to guide bond
adventures to this day double-07
investigates curious goings-on in exotic
far-flung locations he discovers that
the criminal enterprise is the work of
an inscrutable wealthy villain with a
layer henchmen and an over-the-top plan
do you expect me to talk no mr bond i
expect you to die then bond with aid
from a local woman or member of a
villain's inner circle infiltrates and
ultimately destroys the entire operation
typically in the moments before it all
blows up
the very first bond film dr no adheres
closely to this formula from the very
start it's the first time double07
introduces himself on camera
james bond it co-stars ursula andrus as
the prototypical bond girl honey ryder
setting the standard for all the
franchises many sexual innuendo stuffed
names to follow she's known as octopussy
plus dr no introduces the evil
organization spectre though only as a
throwaway reference specter special
executive for counterintelligence
terrorism revenge extortion spectre gets
a bit more screen time in the follow-up
film from russia with love which also
includes an offhand reference to the
organization's leader and bond's future
arch nemesis ernst stavro blofeld at
first he's only referred to as number
one number three is your section ready
to carry out kromstein's directives yes
number one even more spectre details
start to get filled in by 1965's
thunderball including the memorable
briefing scene that was directly
parodied in austin power's international
man of mystery
back in the classic connery days the
gadgets bond would take along on these
missions where traditional 60s spycraft
largely playing around the idea of using
tiny hidden or covert surveillance tools
and weapons that an enemy can't see or
wouldn't be expecting this was an analog
era so the conrad's most memorable
gadgets were purely mechanical in nature
like the cigarette gun from you only
lived twice
1964's goldfinger the third film in neon
series marked the first appearance of
bond's aston martin db5 this vehicle
tricked out by q with a number of
surprises including a smoke screen
bullet shield ejector seat it's just one
of the many that the characters driven
over the course of the series but easily
the most memorable the format
established in these early films
continues throughout the franchise q
shows bond how his equipment works in
the first act then bond road tested
against some bad guys in act two or
three
i believe they call that chekhov's
exploding briefcase no surprise that the
first entry starring connery also
established how james bond interacted
with the women he'd meet on his
adventures typically the early bond
girls fit into a few categories either
allies who like him have a vested
interest in bringing down the villain
turncoats who switch to bond side from
the villains or victims who help bond
and then suffer a terrible fate two
goldfinger characters in particular have
become the prototypical examples of
these archetypes flying ace [ __ ] galore
who works as a pilot for bad guy or
goldfinger but eventually aligns herself
with bond and goldfinger's girlfriend
and accomplice jill masterson who tips
bond off to his card cheating scheme and
pays for it by being dipped in gold
paint and dying from skin asphyxiation
most of the bond girls in connery films
such as lana wood as
plenty o'toole in diamonds are forever
only appear very briefly and are played
more as eye candy than fleshed out
characters but in a departure from how
connery's bond treats women in george
lazenby's on her majesty's secret
service we meet the only woman who's
ever convinced james to settle down
teresa draco played by diana rigg who
would later star as lady olenna tyrell
in game of thrones bond's marriage to
tracy and her death at the hands of
bloodfell subordinate irma bundt would
become one of the few true points of
continuity throughout the entire bond
series until daniel craig at least the
next movie in the series diamonds are
forever finds bond tracking blofeld
presumably for revenge while theresa's
death is mentioned in the spy who love
me for your eyes only license to kill
goldeneye and the world is not enough
roger moore joined the series in 1973
for live and let die and went on to play
bond six more times remaining in the
role for a total of 12 years that's the
record for the longest stint is bond in
history he's also the oldest actor to
ever play double 07 departing the series
after a view to a kill at age 58. more
introduced a more freewheeling and
humorous bond with more of a
tongue-in-cheek joadaviv than the
conriera in some of the films bond even
hints at a level of self-awareness
making the films at times nearly a
parody of the suave manly tough guy
sexiness that dominated the connery
years this trickled down even to the
series cartoonish supporting characters
particularly bumbling southern law man
jw peppa who appeared in both live and
let die and its follow-up the man with
the golden gun the 70s bond films also
reflected some of the popular themes and
genres of the time live and let dye
incorporated elements from
blaxploitation films even casting black
caesar and hell up and harlem star
gloria hendry as the first
african-american bond girl rosie carver
moonraker bond's first adventure in
space came out just two years after
george lucas's star wars changed the
face of blockbuster tentpole filmmaking
forever morzeira also brought a certain
vulnerability to bond
who's functionally an unkillable
superhero in many of his other
incarnations octopussy famously features
the suave secret agent in a clown outfit
and being goofed on by local teens while
hitchhiking while bond gets klutzy on
skis and for your eyes only while he
gets whirled around against his will
spies like us style in moonraker the
scale and size of the missions on which
moore's bond embarks also grew with the
times as the 1970s and 80s introduced
new kinds of groundbreaking special
effects technology and blockbuster films
generally upped the ante on the kinds of
spectacle action fans expected the bond
films did their best to keep pace 1974's
man with the golden gun gives em an
impressively scaled capsized freighter
the rms queen elizabeth as a base of
operations and provides the villainous
skara manga with his own car plane while
bond drives a combo sports car and
submarine in spy who loved me the stunt
work also got more impressively
elaborate the famous 3 000 foot ski jump
from the opening to spy who loved me was
performed by american stuntman and
climber rick sylvester and took three
full weeks of rehearsals in preparation
sylvester also did the stunt work on for
your eyes only as movies grew more
intense and even violent over the years
the more bond series also made the
changeover while he's always had a
license to kill moore's bond is at times
remarkably efficient at doing away with
his enemies as in this famous moment
from the spy who loved me where he
knocked a henchman named sandor off a
building simply by readjusting his tie
in terms of the gadgets the more films
were also upgraded to keep pace with the
times while connery's bond favored tiny
or hidden mechanical devices moore's 07
got some more high-tech applications
like the safe cracking cigarette in
moonraker which presaged a lot of modern
hacking sequences on the bond girlfriend
things started to change as actress maud
adams played two bond girls both
depicted as capable operators in their
own right in the man with the golden gun
she's andrea anders a mistress of
christopher lee's villains garamonga who
betrays him and is then killed as a
consequence then in octopussy she's
introduced as a powerful female villain
the series first though this is
ultimately undermined at the end when
she's knocked out and kidnapped by the
real villain louis jordan as kamal khan
still there were a few exceptions
throughout the more era that hinted at
where the female roles would go in the
future lois chile's holly goodhead in
moonraker is both a brilliant doctor and
a cia agent who proves herself a capable
fighter her help is vital in stopping
the evil drax's master plan and she
actually gets to survive until the end
of the movie she's got it all
the fourth overall actor to play james
bond timothy dalton was originally
offered the role in 1969 but he turned
down the chance to take over for sean
connery after you only lived twice
fearing that he was a bit too young for
double 07. dalton's name came up again
after moore announced a planned
retirement from the bond franchise in
1981 but when he changed his mind and
went forward with for your eyes only
dalton's bond career was delayed again
he finally made his debut in the role in
1987 with the living daylights
interesting side note future bond pierce
brosnan also did a screen test for this
movie dalton's take on the character is
a bit more serious than moore's turning
down the camp and giving him a more
aloof and less jokey demeanor in fact
dalton's very first scene the intro to
living daylights doesn't contain a
single quip
damn that's a hard ass bond in license
to kill dalton's bond literally turns
rogue and has his double-07 status
remote our license to kill is revoked a
first for the entire series as with his
counterpart in the daniel craig years
dalton's bond also maintains more
personal relationships and connects
emotionally with his work license to
kill opens with bond attending the
wedding of his friend now dea agent
felix lighter in a rare glimpse at his
off-duty lifestyle in keeping with
contemporary late 1980s action
franchises the dalton bond films turned
the violent mayhem up to 11. check out
the grisly death waiting for benicio del
toro's brutal cartel henchmen dario in
license to kill
are you all right switch the bloody
machine off see not even equip after a
guy falls into a shredding machine this
bond is all business the missions
reflected the era as well with the
living daylights focused on an american
arms dealer villain and depicting an
ongoing soviet war in afghanistan and
licensed to kill going straight miami
vice with a storyline centered around
bond's pursuit of a florida drug lord
the dalton films are also where you see
bond's female companions begin to truly
enter the modern era kerry lowell as pam
bouvier in license to kill serves as a
wholesale refutation of the classic bond
girl archetype she calls out bonds
womanizing challenges q's suggestion
that seducing women is all part of the
job saves bond from the brutal dario and
even mocks talisa soto's more
conventional bond girl character lupe
lamora i love james so much when timothy
dalton first landed the role of james
bond filming was delayed so he could
complete work on a big screen adaptation
of brenda starr you all remember brenda
starr no not at all that's not really a
movie sure it is check it out
anyway pierce brosnan was first
considered to take up the mantle back at
that time but he had to back out due to
his pre-existing commitment to tv's
remington steel the pieces didn't all
come together for prostate to join the
series until goldeneye which was
originally conceived for timothy dalton
but delayed by legal disputes until 1995
long after he retired from the series
and moved on to harassing the rocketeer
brosnan's approach to bond functions as
a kind of synthesis of all that has come
before like connery he's unflappable and
confident without being brash or smarmy
like more he's quick with a quip and
never too self-serious about being a
larger-than-life kind of figure but like
dalton he's also a man of action and the
centerpiece for some of the series most
grandiose action sequences though
dalton's films had focused on
contemporary bad guys like drug kingpins
the brosnan bond films were the first
ones to take place in a truly post-cold
war reality and the missions reflected a
world in which you couldn't just fall
back on the soviets when you needed
all-purpose bad guys the films came up
with a variety of solutions goldeneye
pit spawned against a former colleague
sean bean as former double 06 alex
trevelyan while tomorrow never dies
co-stars jonathan price is a villainous
media magnate widely read at the time as
a send-up of ted turner bill gates or
rupert murdoch depending on who you
asked plus there's the extremely outside
the box appearance-shifting north korean
colonel tan sun moon who transforms
himself into the european gustav graves
via dna replacement therapy which last i
checked is not a real thing probably the
most significant update to the entire
franchise in the brosnan era was another
personnel shift the introduction in
goldeneye of judy dench as the new m
dench was the first woman to take on the
role and played the first m who was kind
of antagonistic towards bond i think
you're a sexist misogynist dinosaur a
relic of cold war the world is not
enough also foreshadows the closer
relationship the two characters would
develop in the craig films in general
lady characters get a lot more to do in
the brosnan films than any other time in
the franchise's history famke janssen's
goldeneye henchwomen zenya onotop proves
herself as much more than bon's equal in
the battlefield and the bedroom in
tamara never dies michelle yeoh plays
wai lin an extremely capable and
fiendishly clever chinese police officer
who's an equal partner to bond in just
about every way and being michelle yo
she also dominates most of the duo's big
action set pieces most of the brazdan
bond girls get to have real world
credentials elektra king is a devious
and conniving criminal mastermind jinx
is an elite professional assassin and dr
christmas jones is a nuclear scientist
named dr christmas jones
which brings us to daniel craig in the
current era of james bond this of course
is the very first group of films within
the franchise to remain entirely
interconnected with actual linear
continuity we follow james from earning
his double o status at the opening of
casino royale through his various
assignments which have all been tied
together through the pursuit of the evil
organization quantum and ultimately
spectre leading to the reveal of
christoph waltz's blofeld the
personality of craig's bond also breaks
the mold in a variety of ways he's
frequently referred to as a thug and
struggles a bit with the suave seductive
part of the job that came so naturally
to connery's incarnation he's moody and
downbeat and even his jokes tend more
towards sardonic or world weary
observations than zingy one-liners i'm
afraid i'm not that cruel well perhaps
you're just out of practice the action
accordingly is focused more on physical
exertion and brutality the famed parkour
chase from casino royale is among the
most relentless and intense from the
entire series and showed off a new
physicality for bond it's notable too
that craig's bond is often visibly
exhausted by his efforts not to mention
sometimes seriously wounded at their
conclusion though brosnan was the first
bond to endure actual on-screen torture
during the world is not enough casino
royale's brutality ups the ante in an
extended sequence that's almost
unbearable to watch should you happen to
possess a pair of testicles
bond's missions in the craig films are
also more ground level and realistic we
still get wealthy european villains with
grandiose plans but they're making less
visible ostentatious aesthetic choices
opting for hidden or covert layers
instead of floating palaces at sea or
volcano bases as well their plans are
less maniacally over the top and more
intricately plotted and careful
particularly silva's devious attempt to
take out m and skyfall which owes more
than a little debt to the joker's
finished game plan in the dark knight
with its focus on gritty realism craig
series naturally also downplays the use
of zany gadgets a gun and a radio not
exactly christmas is it are you
expecting an exploding pen though there
are a few fun moments to highlight in
casino royale bond's car comes outfitted
with a defibrillator which is handy i
mean it's not zany but it's handy
as for bond girls this time around they
not only get their own backstories but
their own narratives and personal
missions these are characters whose
journeys intersect with bond but are not
defined by his presence or even
dependent on him to reach their
conclusion government accountant vesper
lind and casino royale has her own
agenda that we only come to understand
by the end of quantum of solace long
after her death the craig films also
significantly deepened and enhances
relationships with a number of the
franchise best-known supporting
characters this is particularly true of
judy dench's m who has a lot of her
backstory filled in and takes on an
almost maternal role for bond by the
conclusion of her final appearance in
skyfall having continuity also means
more opportunities to work in supporting
players like jeffrey wright's felix
lighter and also worth noting for the
record cnn's wolf blitzer appears as
himself in both skyfall and mission
impossible fallout indicating that both
franchises could in fact be taking place
in a shared alternate reality the blitz
reverse
and there you have it not a small amount
of evolving for a character that
conventional wisdom would hold never
actually evolves very much at all so
enjoy watching james bond turn yet
another corner in no time to die and
keep it here on phantom entertainment
for more about all your favorite
franchises and how they're keeping up
with the relentless march of history or
just who's going to star in the next
sequel whichever really it's all good
[Music]
you